mais avant de s'intéresser à ces mesures
anti qu'ovide en france et voir ce qui
va changer pour notre quotidien on fait
un petit détour par les états unis à new
york où tous les employés du secteur
privé sont désormais dans l'obligation
d'être vacciné annoncé cet après midi du
maire de la ville qui a franchi ce pas
alors que les cas de variants omikron
ont été détectés dans l'état de new york
pour en parler on retrouve thomas bonne
et notre correspondant aux états unis
bonsoir thomas alors comment le maire
justifie cette décision assez
étonnante pour les états unis thomas
oui alors il faut rappeler que new york
avait été très fortement touché par le
cos vite 19 notamment en 2020 avec des
milliers de décès et le maire de la
ville de new york qualifie aujourd'hui à
ces mesures comme une attaque préventive
et audacieuse contre le coc vie 19 alors
que le nombre de cas augmente et qu'il y
à aussi donc l'émergence du variant
omicron il veut absolument dit il éviter
les confinements et les restrictions
dans la plus grande ville américaine
écoutez le
au micro des dieux au temps froid qui
nous le savons présente un véritable
défi avec le co vite sous toutes ses
formes ce sont les fêtes de fin d'année
qui approchent et il se passe beaucoup
de choses ce que nous voyons maintenant
dans d'autres parties du monde est
vraiment très préoccupant nous voyons
des restrictions revenir un peu partout
nous assistons à deir confinement
regardez l'allemagne en ce moment une
nation si forte à bien des égards mais
la situation là bas est devenu vraiment
préoccupante alors maintenant ils
rétablissent de nombreuses restrictions
que nous espérions tous être une
histoire passée nous ne pouvons pas
laisser ces restrictions revenir nous ne
pouvons pas avoir de confinement ici à
new york nous devons continuer d'avancer
alors concrètement tous les employés du
secteur privé des entreprises et des
commerces basée à new york devront être
vaccinées d'ici le 27 décembre prochain
autre mesure qui concerne cette fois les
enfants ceux âgés de 5 à 11 ans ils
devront montrer une preuve de
vaccination à partir du 14 décembre pour
pouvoir accéder à certaines activités
extrascolaires alors il faut rappeler
que le 1er novembre dernier déjà le
maire de la ville de new york avait
décidé d'imposer la vaccination
obligatoire pour les employés municipaux
ce qui avait provoqué quelques
mouvements de contestation dans les
rangs des policiers ou encore à des
pompiers on peut dire que new york est
la ville qui va le plus loin en matière
d'obligation de vaccination aux états
unis encore plus loin que les mesures
annoncées au mois de novembre par joe
biden qui je vous le rappelle avait
voulu imposer la vaccination aux
employés mais seulement des entreprises
de plus de 100 salariés une mesure qui a
été bloqué suite à une contestation en
justice et d'ailleurs il est aussi
probable que les mesures annoncées ce
lundi par le maire de la ville de new
york soit contesté en justice merci
thomas abonnés en direct de washington